this morning on the dish
a woman who adds an extra spice to all
her endeavors
asma khan is the british-based indian
chef who's attracted a huge
following through her london restaurants
her cookbooks and
profile on the netflix series chef's
table
and while she's known for her authentic
indian cuisine
her approach to staffing her kitchen is
anything but traditional
from london mts tayab has her story
so when i get from the lift i just give
it to you asma khan knows how to command
a kitchen
yeah it's perfect it's perfect but it's
not the life the chef and social justice
activists saw for herself growing up in
calcutta
as the second daughter born into an
indian royal family
this princess yes princess can not only
handle the heat
okay two doubles first okay okay asha
give me one mug one haleem she also
leads a team of cooks
unlike anywhere else all women of color
and most like her
second daughters i'm a second daughter
and you know what does that mean in your
culture
disaster because you're not the boy
everybody wanted
tell us about your kitchen so it's an
all-female kitchen which is very unusual
you will never find a restaurant
anywhere in the world
cooking you know south asian food with
an all-female kitchen
i would never have even sat down on a
table and
with these women in india because of the
class caste religious differences
between
people but today they are like my own
family
and for them this is liberation it set
them free
for khan learning how to cook the food
she grew up eating as a child in eastern
india
also set her free after getting married
in 1991 and moving to england
she in her own words didn't even know
how to boil an egg
and ached for the flavors of home we
don't realize
how it is part of who we are the air we
breathe part of
you know our soul i really
understood this when i had an arranged
marriage
i moved to cambridge and i was living
with a stranger
who i was trying to make friends with
and then you know the ache of not eating
your own food
was overwhelming after studying for a
phd in british constitutional law
khan returned to india to learn how to
recreate the tastes of her childhood
back in britain her love of the complex
cuisine blossomed
into a new life first hosting supper
parties for strangers at her home
then opening a restaurant the darjeeling
express publishing a renowned cookbook
and now a major expansion moving her
wildly popular eatery to london's
historic covent garden but you have to
start tasting stuff
because i'm i know that i've been
speaking to you
without so you you can be you can choose
whatever you want to start off with
right well i want to start with what's
in front of me here
this is so this is the uh bunch forum
try a bit uh and it's uh very bengoli
okay and what gives it its red hue
it's this tomato it's really the
sourness that comes through yes
followed by the heat yeah and and this
is how you have to spice
you spice the layers curry is britain's
most popular food
but the often creamy dishes served with
thick breads in restaurants around the
country
are a far cry from the authentic indian
dining experience
khan wants her customers to enjoy like
this beetroot raita
an electric huge yogurt to soothe the
palate
yes bubblegum color and what is nice
about this is that it has only one
spice in it which is roasted and put in
i won't put you on the spot and ask you
to identify it but it's
is it jeera yes
i got the name right now you got the
name right in english is
i didn't even know
your mom did a good job raising you so
that is that
the biryani wow taste it because it's
very very gentle but it's the classic
kolkata biryani that khan is most
renowned for
a royal rice dish cooked in layers for
several hours
her carrot halva is also work intensive
do that
the dessert is made with milk sugar and
spices that require several hours of
near
constant stirring it's
just awesome and you can taste that
this tastes like my childhood oh
it really i mean i'm having a moment
here because
my mother would make this part of khan's
mission is for her customers to have a
more complete understanding
of south asian cuisine i mean i always
find it very hard when people
come to my restaurant and say can i have
none and i said i don't even know how to
make it
and then look at your sound to india and
i was thinking like most indians would
not
know how to make it or eat it yeah they
don't have it at home no and also the
other thing is everyone thinks you have
a tandoori in your house your house will
catch fire
the only flames khan wants to fan give
the chutney on the sides huh
are of understanding
and through her food she hopes her table
will bring people
who might not otherwise come together
i've had such an extraordinary time
eating your food
what do you want people to feel when
they eat your food
i want them to get up from the stable
not hating people who look like me
because it's about breaking bread
together
you eat my food you understand me a bit
next time you're on the underground you
sit next to a woman maybe her coat
smells of masala
look at her in the eye don't hate us
don't label us you've opened this
extraordinary restaurant
in an extraordinary time in our life
what do you want people to experience
when we walk through these doors
i want them to feel this is a homecoming
it doesn't you don't need to be south
issue you don't need anything
but for all of us who have not seen
family who've been cut off
who have been so you know not able to
live our normal life
i want this restaurant to be your refuge
come here put your burden down
and eat for cbs this morning saturday
london wow khan what
a woman that was really sweet oh really
incredible messages
and the food looked amazing and i'm
impressed with mts picking out
the spices i know very impressive show
the different side